in that previous episode he was here so
I bought an old [ __ ] around he just
disappeared whoa-oh-aah Jason the [ __ ]
oh whoa
sharing a mascot Shelby I'm a private
detective the families of the victims of
the origami killer asked me to
investigate the murders help you there's
nothing you can do
my son's dead do you hear me shut don't
cry Sol everything's gonna be here I
hate you what the hell I don't remember
this what are we doing here
how did we did how did how did the hell
what car keys under origami oh I'll go
Andrew
my name is very bad welcome back to
heavy rain we're gonna plays my favorite
character and actually found out later
that he's gay
so that means I'm not homophobic because
I like him even though he's gay I'm glad
I had to prove that anyway this is
awkward are you then okay cool
sorry about that I
it's weird it's really cool though I
really really like him like it's one of
my favorite characters ever in
videogames I don't know what's up with
these drugs things and it makes my hands
shake and I don't like it let's get out
of the car breasts
all right detective pants FBI comes to
investigate it's [ __ ] raining I hate
my job all right
what's up ladies she's always section
officer at least step back agent nah man
James F FBI you got a badge or something
what the hell do your thing out yeah of
course yeah under the helmet I have this
freaking fries oh [ __ ] there you go
that's right
check you can pass and tell me how to do
all right let's go down it said Blake
what is this I'm looking for lieutenant
Blake see you around
I saw him arrive earlier he's here right
where cherry out Thanks
cool you can ask him even though you
walk forward that's kind of neat little
detail what am I doing here
oh hi remember badass mode activate hell
yeah video memo recording agent four
seven zero to three nominated Tuesdays
went today from my batch 2011 ah my god
14 a all right so this is our tool or
whatever to find evidence
I guess they only give FBI these kind of
things it's a really cool thing I always
had one of these good look for treasures
I like a clue let's go and burn now why
did I take off my glasses
all right let's check this these are
some high-tech stuff I don't know how
this all scarred eyes oh oh
good arm I am unrelated to the
investigation
all right let's look for sergeant Blake
I know that [ __ ] is somewhere
[ __ ] Izzy I think is over hey yep let's
look for clues while we're at it I find
something why don't we get it's called
the re now a very common sample of no
interest comes one of the policemen
present on [ __ ] Andrew Simpson all
these [ __ ] on my shed oh well alright
well are you okay there
guess it's shaky with the drugs
lieutenant play I'm agent Norman Jayden
from the FBI I went by your office this
morning they told me you'd be supper if
you're looking for rain dead bodies and
highways you come to my mansion Harris
Mike we tell that [ __ ] with the
bulldozer to stop for five minutes I
can't hear myself take care
right away lieutenant
well I gotta look for more clues
actually so I were walking some guy
taking his dog birds found a box like
this were much more rare based on what
we've seen looks like the work of the ah
yes they are a gamma cannon were there
any witnesses any witnesses
none yet given the neighborhood I'd be
surprised if anybody saw anything any
news on the coroner that he's on his way
lieutenant we've been waiting for an
hour for play hey I thought so
what precaution there are a lot of
people out yeah they could just walk on
it aren't you afraid your men might
destroy some clues you don't find proof
sitting behind a desk we're not gonna
have a trample on things into the ground
if we're not in the FBI well no no of
course not that's not I meant was stupid
son of a [ __ ] Tony I don't want to see a
single shit-stirring journalist with a
mile in here you got it yes I got it so
what cause we know the cause of death
there are no marks on the body whatever
chances are he was drowned oh yeah he
drowns his victims
well what time was the time of death
been established based on the rigor
mortis must be less than six hours oh
[ __ ] we should know more what's the
coroner has had a look listen up I'm a
little busy here why don't we discuss
all this a little later back at the old
mine no problem I understand do you mind
if I have a look around
be my guest
hey Jade you come and see me if you find
of course yeah yeah sang my hat
no [ __ ] you alright we are one man team
here we don't need him we got the re
alright let's look for some more clothes
I actually know where to go anyway so
let's stroll away Elba hey it's jolly
good jolly good Jam let's see what the
aura says over here no nothing for sure
you can
ah there we go Jane what the steps leads
to this place and I don't even have to
find a step oh my god very common traces
of blood detected on the first man so he
is a blood report indicates an advanced
and long-lasting state of exhaustion I
II got that from the holy [ __ ] all right
whoa oh no my soaked it was beautiful
well oh [ __ ] I suck at these Circle
Square no that's the triangle [ __ ]
doesn't matter climb like a Bosch climb
like a bath there you go girl
a little dirty and disgusting but hey a
little dirt ain't no killer buddy
get up there bro
allow this is like a big deal oh no come
on bro you can't keep going up Jesus
tell you to stop
whoa I'm click Oh Artu haha alright
no no no no no no not all of it
holy [ __ ] that was dangerous I wonder
what the other cops are thinking it's
like what they're not FBI guy dude
it must be out of his feet I love that
stuff alright I could do it now don't
worry about bread ham yay so you escaped
through here huh
well I guess our trail ends here
what we got anything here we go
as a good chance together killers
all right
this is actually really really important
I'm not gonna leave this area until we
actually got all the things because if
you don't find all the clues it might
cause some trouble to change things in
the future
tire tracks on the side of the road
behind the railroad line it may be the
killer's car
I guess the trail ends here Wow come on
a [ __ ] Ola
oh no is that evidence and tear well we
got to go and look a little more
actually because I want to get the good
ending that's their way
that's gone partay
all right let's go whoo X
it's not even next I'm really fastened
to all right Stan all right down again
we got whoa hello [ __ ] no not up oh
[ __ ] no no no no what are you doing oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] all right let's go
down and back to the office all right
there we go
not a problem how's it going everyone
just one little thing I want to check
out this little house here where the
body inside it might actually help ya
know it gets a little tense it's kind of
disturbing in my opinion
Harry common victims lying on his back
no visible signs of violence
it's kind of disturbing
I don't actually get to see the boy well
can we look around all right
no no no go out
think I've seen all there is to see all
right I guess we go then all right we
got what we came for
we got a little dirt on us that son of a
[ __ ] I'm gonna leave I see you in the
office right okay see you later [ __ ]
it kind of looks like another youtuber
do you speak just say it not this
character the Olly Cobb all right let's
go
yeah
let's do some business and the others
hello tell ya later
do I actually get to drive the car back
that is splendid hello it's good good
job there trick is only 12 minutes
nice going pits I even get to start the
engine call put on some music I would
like that some maybe some bait though I
would be lovely why do I feel like the
killer is in the back of the car or some
[ __ ] like that and this is shaking
hope you can see my face I know his
light means
Oh
and we're back to our beautiful little
you unlock the new bonus all right cool
that is a bat or bad that is a fox a fox
that is your mama's vagina two faces
back-to-back that is death death death
did you not hear me [ __ ] deaf
I don't really get this part it's kind
of weird and he has a Mac so gay
just kidding it's not gay it's just
really homosexual I got its face I have
the results of your MRI scan everything
seems to be normal
there is no physical damage from the
outside I like a week you know or this
sorry natural psychological condition
top notch it's like God you know it's
not easy but you've got to start over
you can't tell me what to do I'm not
responsible for what I set down hmm it's
my fault Jason is dead it'd still be
alive I've been looking out for him
you're right
it was an accident accidents happen
every day you can't blame yourself
forever for your son's death it's right
you gotta let it go bruh how is Sean he
[ __ ] hates me
it's distant he's a very solitary kid
you know very focused within himself
he's really close to his mother
let's get friend with me he's more
distant and what about you Ethan what
are you you feel like I haven't I felt
like Phil depressed I no longer want to
live I have no reason to continue yeah
not even for your son not even for Sean
man I couldn't save Jason Sean doesn't
need a father like me hey don't say that
I heard is exaggerating is there
something else you wanted to tell me
Ethan oh yeah well we tell him about it
nothing no
no that's the end of this session we'll
continue this conversation they can't
wait
you were lucky Ethan it's very rare to
survive such a traumatic accident you
mean survive
I don't exactly feel like exactly but I
have a beer now it's time to do some
damage Janna
all right I don't know what that was all
about
ah I love this pine that's beautiful
so house cold how did things go to
school today I was punished because I
didn't do my oh yeah that was my fault
oh well I'm sorry about that next time
I'll have ya next time
really put together that okay Shawnee
Shaw
can I call the Shawnee Chou is there a
problem here between us it's something
the matter Shawn no I'm all right
you don't look all right let me slap you
can I slap you you want to play aren't
you gonna go play with the other kids
I don't feel yeah [ __ ] we can just
chill here
all right hungry do you want to eat
something
Oh fine
Jace this guy's kid you're a [ __ ] all
right what do you want what do you want
all right
a boomerang oh yeah I [ __ ] Rock ADIZ
no cuz it suck I can never make a
comeback I'll show you can I give it a
try it's gonna love this he's gonna want
to suck my dick over to this alright
r1 there we go Oh
watch ah where and then I gotta catch it
oh yeah yeah [ __ ] then go and
see that you know any hot mom see that
let me do that again
oh yeah
oh haha all right this time I'm Hunt mom
better be watching
we're flying Shawn's face it would be
good to a choppa no I did it twice if
you want to give it a try oh yeah you're
probably right
tomorrow let's try together main thing
is to get the right position our idling
I gotta throw it straight and a little
to the right a little to the right all
right ah apart now Sean let's just give
up you can't do this Sean lets us give
up ha ha but-but-but all right sorry
yeah
let's face it Oh all right there we go
all right Sean our one put your leg out
back now go Sean you can do it it's
gonna be so happy I want to punch his
face
Wow Shawn dinner I did it oh my god good
job Shawn see that wasn't so hard that's
a little sweet god damn it that was a
little sweet
now go [ __ ] off okay I like him a little
more now even though I hate them all
right Shawn you happy now buddy you
don't mind if I go a hot hit on your
fights Mitch mom's that okay so you want
to play on this C song I haven't been on
a seesaw in a long time
what do you think all right steady
let's see saw the [ __ ] out of each other
this is good times I'm loving the good
times hanging out with my son let's go
and see saw in the Sun come on dad maybe
all right I'll make you fly all right ha
ha oh [ __ ]
ha ha this is what the game is all about
just these random moments and the music
comes and you're like it's actually kind
of nice enjoying this even though the
Sun is little annoying but hey I'll take
it it's [ __ ] life he needs to work on
it okay if my son ever laughs like that
I'll be sure to tell him ho ho boy just
kidding
Oh
I'm flattered that's nice strong Talib
you can't do that he looks exactly like
the kid from happy wheels I think that's
why I don't like him all right I think
you can go here but it's actually
annoying it's [ __ ] so let's just go on
the swing instead you can go the
carousel but you gotta buy [ __ ] hey
you want to go to money on the swing
thanks forever I'll push you alright
it's becoming a little better
am I going alright
not sure but yeah oh [ __ ]
alright ha ha
beautiful beautiful moment ha ha ha all
right this is laughing a lot less now
actually enjoy it it's quite nice quite
nice indeed
alright Chung digit that was yeah I'm
glad you think so you're so lame ha ha
[ __ ] smile forever imprinted in my
brain
let's go looks like range beautiful
alright let's go Sean where's your bag
there it is let's get the hell out of
here
you know I didn't mean what I said
before I was just angry
you were right to be angry I wasn't very
nice to you either
ah I like his backpack why are we going
Sean hey Shan Shan ebike Shan my watch I
die is he following me or what's going
on here no where is it going what in the
hell what is it
what it hey Dad can I wrong you know can
I sure go pick a horse and get on I'll
get it ok now I remember
all right one please that's a dollar and
now we go the carousel the [ __ ] did he
go the [ __ ] did he go are they
oh no it's happening oh [ __ ]
ah
ah Oh what's gonna happen I don't even
know gonna end this episode here but
lacking favorite if you enjoyed
subscribe become a read the day and I'll
see you next episode
Everly that's murder you know I love you